tyler murray taking on tom brady's old
team in new england the patriots a week
after not being able to handle desean
watson yeah were able to handle kyler
murray you took a look back at that game
what did you see about how they were
able to slow down one of the most
dynamic and electric players that that
i've seen in my life in the nfl yeah
well i mean it is interesting and i mean
i had the first thing let's let's talk
about just the kyler murray deshawn
watson aspect of that right i mean
desean watson not as athletic as kyler
murray but a better pocket passer
and
better at when people are around him he
could still make throws down the middle
of the field and do those type of things
that's a get part of the game that kyla
murray is a little limited in you can't
have it all right and one thing i'll say
about kyle murray you don't see a lot of
completions 10 and 15 yards down the
middle of the field new england knew
that
they didn't even guard that part of the
field at times but as always the
patriots had a game plan and it was all
about one thing and to me it was
don't let kylo murray
run around on us and cause crazy plays
and i did that to me the game plan
showed if we could stop that they felt
like they could stop everything else
and that's where i get into the kyla
murray and the arizona offense needs to
be my more diverse and you know have
other ways to attack you other than just
being in the spread offense and him
running around and making plays that way
with quick throws and all of that
new england was all over some of their
past concepts and they just did a
phenomenal job of their hey stand around
you know rush five they'd mush the
middle mike had three guys so kyler
murray couldn't step up in the pocket
and then you know we see the three
rockets up his butt he sees the red seat
part and all of a sudden he rips off 30
yards up the middle they were very
cognizant of clogging the middle and
then the outside guys didn't really rush
they kind of just came off the ball and
they just evaluated his movements and
then when they tried to see him throw or
do anything like that hands were up and
all of that stuff because he's a smaller
type quarterback and that's going to be
another way as we see to defend kyla
murray but as usual new england really
well coached up on stopping the best
thing another team does
yeah and and look kyla murray's
production has dropped
uh since the hail murray yeah teams are
starting to figure out how to defend him
it took a while
um and and you know i think part of it
is some defenses just assumed we can't
defend
fast and elusive
you can't effectively shut that down but
they have found a way starting with the
seahawks continuing with the patriots to
maybe minimize the damage he can do
force him to stay in the pocket
keep him from from
killing you that way that's what it was
plays and it was like once a game they
would set you up with that that read
option where everything's flowing to the
right and kyler keeps the ball and just
shoots through
we haven't seen that lately no we
haven't i know and that's where you get
into
they need more diversity in their
offense now one of the things i saw from
this game is they got into some two and
three tight end sets a little bit
because they're trying to limit new
england from you know all the secondary
people standing up and doing all this
crazy stuff but i think that's the the
real thing you know
with with arizona that jumps out to me
hey they got all the base plays and the
offense is good but cliff kingsbury is
still new to the nfl and i think he's
still finding his way in tinkering and i
see more and more stuff
but the biggest thing
is i'm seeing teams as you've heard me
say this the last few weeks
there's just too many moments in games
where teams are all over their past
concepts it tells me there's things that
are predictable about what they do
and because of that it's allowing teams
to
you know put more one more egg into the
we're gonna stop kyler murray from
running around and making plays happen
basket and that's the big issue and
that's when i talk about like offensive
diversity hey i'm not talking like hey
jalen hurts one let one play last night
he comes in for two plays and hey look
we're diverse we did something else no
offensive diversity as you know mike
with great offenses like we see with
sean payton or drew brees or brady and
back in the new england days or even
aaron rodgers right now hey one drive we
can go down the field with three wide
receivers and
never take them off the field ten ten
play drive three receivers next drive we
can come out and play two tight ends
three tight end set one receiver and we
can drive down the field and do it that
way too that's offensive diversity and i
think that's the next phase the
cardinals need to get to to help out
kyla murray and
help him get on the edge where are the
speed sweeps with arizona where's that
fake stuff where's the ability to create
one extra step for kyle murray to get on
the edge and 30 yard run and do those
type of things to me they don't do
enough of that stuff either to kind of
really totally utilize his great talents
and uh that's going to be a problem for
this team that is now six and five you
take away the hail murray and all other
things equal they're five and six and
struggling yeah to stay in the playoff
field and it's not going to be an easy
road for the cardinals the rest of the
way
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports